[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france 24 doctor muy buen día
hablemos hoy de la situación de la
vacunación en américa latina' ayer la
organización panamericana de la salud la
opc se declaró alarmada por la situación
en algunos países de américa latina qué
está pasando con naciones como colombia
venezuela argentina bolivia uruguay que
parecen ir hacia un nuevo pico de los
contagios
es esa aceleración de casos que estamos
viendo en este momento raúl responde en
gran parte también a la presencia de
unos linajes virales como este linaje
emanados que es un linaje que se ha
estado extendiendo paulatinamente en
brasil es altamente circulante pérdida
se ha detectado en todos los países y
probablemente se explique la aceleración
de los casos además de otros
determinantes sociales es decir que por
ahora en los linajes virales que se
están volviendo preguntas en la región
explica en esa segregación de casos
ahora doctor además de estos linajes y
variantes como usted lo estaba diciendo
hay otros factores que expliquen este
aumento de casos
estos determinantes sociales tienen que
ver con la aglomeración o un periodo de
vacaciones de semana santa en donde hubo
un comportamiento inadecuado y explica
que en algunas regiones se haya
incrementado el número de casos y
definitivamente los determinantes
económicos donde la informalidad laboral
obliga a las personas tengan que
trabajar haciendo exposición de digamos
con otras personas pues hace que hayan
estas causas sociales también como
aporte en la nueva celebración de casos
en brasil aunque hay un descenso en los
casos los contagios graves parecen estar
afectando a gente más joven que explica
el productor puede ser a lo mejor por
estas variantes del virus que se han
presentado en brasil
si es la explicación más lógica que
tenemos además de que la población joven
no hay mayor movilidad entonces hay
mayor posible de contagio y eso hace que
haya incrementado mucho el número de
casos y es el número de casos como
siempre ha pasado pues hay unos que
conservan gravedad es preocupante que
menores de 40 años están ocupando las
unidades de contenido en brásil y es
probable que estos linajes sean un poco
más agresivos que lo que estamos
conociendo antes de la enfermedad y si
eso se extiende en la región pues va a
ser un problema mucho más complejo para
poder manejar las futuras contingencias
y los futuros casos ahora doctor le
quiero preguntar dos cosas la primera
que si está previsto que haya nuevos
picos y la segunda si estos picos se
pueden prevenir
la lógica de la pandemia es que mientras
haya un virus circulante hay seres
humanos susceptibles baja tasa de
vacunación y comportamiento social que
permite el acercamiento van a ver nuevos
pips de que es predecible no podemos
eliminar el virus no tenemos
tratamientos efectivos esto nos quedan
dos determinantes el comportamiento
social y la vacunación debemos acelerar
acelerar el proceso de vacunación y
mantener el alejamiento físico el uso de
la mascarilla y las medidas de seguridad
que conocemos muy estrictamente durante
ese tiempo y la única forma que podemos
prevenir las futuras o las que
seguramente se pueden ver doctor en
chile en cambio la situación se ha
estabilizado un poco tiene esto que ver
con los avances en la vacunación en la
nación austral
es un ejemplo de que la vacunación si se
hace masiva y consistente disminuye la
aceleración de casos y por eso es
importante que en la región se adquieran
de forma armónica en las vacunas porque
tenemos que formarnos todos no solamente
unos países sin la vacunación no es
masiva no es exitosa entonces chile es
un gran ejemplo como lo es israel y el
reino unido en la actualidad doctor muy
rápidamente cuál es el panorama que nos
espera en nuestra región hablando de la
evolución de la pandemia de kobe 19
nuestra nuestros determinantes actuales
es conseguir más vacunas mantener una
estructura que nos permita el
alejamiento físico solventar los
problemas económicos que son
determinantes en la región y mantener
esa disciplina social que no hemos
tenido en este ámbito hemos aprendido si
hacemos algo de eso podemos disminuir la
pérdida de unos ticos y es que se
desangren tantos costes sobre todo en la
población joven que nos preocupe tanto
doctor nuevamente gracias por estar
siempre con nosotros en france 24 dando
los consejos y hablando de esta pandemia
que nos afecta a todos de una manera u
otra ustedes también gracias por estar
siempre con nosotros conectados al otro
lado de la pantalla
[Música]